the jurogan experience your um
your um
coffee thing if you're if you're really
into it you get into the flavors and you
get into drinking it black i used to
always add cream to my coffee and i
still do if i get starbucks because no
offense starbucks but generally speaking
their black coffee does not taste that
good
a lot of it is like overcooked and burnt
did you i read that howard schultz's um
biography
and it like turned me into a huge
starbucks fan because the guy is just so
inspirational you know he like brought
he brought coffee culture to america
like i mean coffee didn't exist here
before like the espresso culture and
espresso bars he just
you know for whether you like the coffee
or don't or whatever you say he was it's
really phenomenal well they have that
one machine if you go to that one
machine that was it called the clover
yeah like sucks the coffee yeah what is
that called yeah is that a quote yeah
but i think starbucks like bottom all
right because they're like this is too
good yeah yeah yeah
he partnered with them it's part of his
book he like found this guy that was
doing this thing and he was like i want
to partner with you and bring this to
the world it's like it's a genius piece
of kit there was a starbucks near my
house in california that had one and i
used to always get that i would drink
black but other than that i just pour
some cream in there it's good enough but
i generally like a
dark roast black coffee and i've gotten
it's a thing it's like you get
accustomed to the flavor and the taste
yeah that's the machine yeah it's really
wild like you you pour the beans in
there and then you have to kind of whisk
it and stir it
and there's some sort of a vacuum prod
it is called a clover right
and there's a vacuum process that
creates the coffee and it's the perfect
temperature coffee and then you got this
weird hockey puck of
grounds that come to the top and then
they just sort of scraped that hockey
puck out there a little squeegee it's
amazing but i so this is like matt and i
have this conversation all the time
because i'm like you know part of coffee
culture at a coffee bar is the like
theater of it all yes and so when you go
to coffee but then i'm like we're
writing this cookbook i'm like dude can
we just actually
make
coffee and taste it all these different
ways and try and break down what's
really important like do i gotta steep
the beans and then wait 10 minutes and
then start again and get the rest of
water in there do i have to you know is
that is that is that a blooming process
really matter like how long before i
grind the beans and we came to the
conclusion that like
oh some of the things are and and and
look if you've got a morning tradition
that includes you know putting on your
monocle and like
but for me we were like actually fresh
grinding your beans makes a huge
difference and then
i love a pour over coffee um
and and blooming the coffee matters like
getting it getting it wet first and then
starting and then putting a little more
water in afterwards so it has some time
sort of you know you know what i'm
talking about no explain that so like
matt wrote the recipe in the cookbook
but basically it's like you know a an
old-school glass drip coffee maker
actually makes really great coffee like
an old bun machine
where
the drip comes down slow so it gets the
the ground coffee wet and it gives it a
chance to like absorb the water
and then
the flavor to filter out whereas if you
just pour all the water over dry beans
right away like a french press it
doesn't well french press it steeps it
in there right right french press you
pour it in you let it steep in there and
then you strain it out
but a lot of people when when they do
like a pour over coffee or whatever
they're doing they just
put the beans in their filter ground
beans in the filter pour the hot water
over and let it drain through and you
leave a lot of the flavor behind whereas
if you
get it wet let it sit for a minute
and then pour the rest of the water
through you have you get more extraction
of the flavor so when you say get it wet
like how wet well i put 20 percent of
the water in so like for me i do 21
grams of coffee and 350 grams of water
and that's a that's an eater very
specific well everything is this way i'm
a psycho about everything i do i mean
salting meat i got i do it by the by the
percentage weight everything's
percentage weight for me really you
don't just like salt bae it no no i mean
i do the salt bae after i weigh it first
you know
obviously um no everything everything
for me is is is that's the way you great
great consistency and that's the way you
can really
figure out what you did wrong and get it
better is by by adjusting it
incrementally right
like
so the that that 21 grams of of ground
coffee for for you know whatever it is a
full-size cup of coffee whatever this is
beautiful but do i get to keep this one
oh yeah sure right is that i just
offered that to you no no see yeah it's
probably 100 it's for you thank you that
would be a great thank you i'll drink my
coffee and look at every day beautiful
um i'll get weird
it's handsome um and uh but so i take i
take the first hundred grams of water
and i pour it over
and then i go and i take my my i do some
of my morning activities like before i
start the shower i do like and then i
come back and i finish the coffee the
other day how much time in between
depends on what i have for dinner the
night before really oh so you take a
take a and then yeah
but so like 15 minutes yeah it could be
any amount of time it's just really it
should it'll i don't like to drink my
coffee super hot so i don't mind that
extra time to cool it down a bit but i
think you just want to give it about two
minutes for the coffee to bloom for to
for the whatever you know there are
scientists that would explain like the
starches absorbing the water which is
allowing them to release because if you
think about pouring coffee over ground
it's like little ground pebbles of
coffee beans you pour the water over and
you want the water to have a chance to
leach out the flavor that's inside of
the ground and like espresso is really
fast and you grind it really really fine
right
whereas
maybe a french press is
going to steep for quite a while so you
grind it quite a bit coarser and so pour
over maybe somewhere in between but it
still needs a few few seconds to steep
but that's what you prefer the pour over
yeah i'm a far over guy